also drop a Kenny saw it on the map
there uh it is happening this weekend
more traffic more closures Nate
Tannenbaum is live this morning at the
project site with what to expect this
weekend and it starts Nate this evening
Clock Tonight John the complete closure
of I-15 before we get there though you
mentioned that Tropicana itself is
closed and that actually happened last
weekend and that's going to continue
until Monday and that's when I-15 is
scheduled to reopen let's bring in
Lynette Russell from the Nevada
Department of Transportation project
manager Leonard thanks for getting up
early with us this morning thank you
Nate and so the closure of the I-15 is
so Tropicana the westbound Lanes can be
taken down right that is correct yes
because when was that bridge built when
was Tropicana built over the 15. well
actually built into this is the first
phase was
of Las Vegas was right about a hundred
thousand people yeah and we widened it
in the 90s in the early 90s added the
additional Lanes across I-15 as well as
the flyover population at that time was
about a million people
and so it's time for an update because
the new finished Tropicana is going to
have a whole have more Lanes it's going
to have more Lanes on Tropicana and also
for the ramps on and off ramps we'll
have more Lanes so better access through
here and the flyover ramp came down
because I understand it didn't meet the
current federal requirements the flyover
with the way that Tropicana is currently
soon to be was currently yeah
constructed was fine but we have to
raise the height of Tropicana Tropicana
with the original 1960s construction was
too low so it gets hit sometimes yeah so
that's not going to happen anymore and
we're going to be back with you or
Justin Hopkins coming up in the next
half hour but the bottom line for you is
I-15 is closing in both directions
between Flamingo and Russell at 10
o'clock tonight until 5 Monday morning
John cherry